good morning millennials we are so
excited to welcome to the podcast
a comedy icon and now a fellow podcaster
chelsea handler hello chelsea thank you
so much for being here
oh hello girls how are you we are
good we're so honored and humbled to
have you joining the prestigious circle
of podcasters you're really elevating
our brand and we really appreciate it
oh you're well you're very welcome girls
okay give me your podcast dear chelsea
invite space podcast first of all you've
done
everything you've conquered like tv
books why podcasting
well i mean everybody has a podcast so
obviously i
i had one and then they i i had a first
one when i
was on my book tour like two years ago
and then when i was done with it was a
limited one when i was done they said
well you should do another one a more
long-term one and
i just wanted to figure out a way to do
it in a more creative way than just
adding to the mix of podcasts and i
thought you know what who's more
unqualified to give advice than me
yes 100 yeah so the format of your
podcast dear chelsea
you have people submit advice and you
just give your take on it based on your
life experience
how and why did you land on that format
like is it important to you to be able
to connect with people listening to the
podcast why did you choose that
uh well because i've been through a lot
of therapy and people do come to me a
lot for problems like i'm a crisis
manager i'm very good in a crisis
so i figured oh what would be a good way
to not make this just
another vanity project to make it about
other people instead of making it about
myself
so it was a great way to connect with
people you know have my fans call in
people call in with real serious
problems
and if i'm out of my wheelhouse you know
i have an expert come in
or somebody who specializes in eating
disorders or
you know a psychiatrist or something
like that you know would
depending on what the problems are so
yeah it's been really good i mean some
problems are really stupid and those are
fun
and some are really really serious well
we're going to get your take because we
have some
listeners with some questions for you
but what would you say is your style of
advice giving like are you someone who's
super
prudent like what claudia and i are we
differ in terms of the advice that we
give but
what's your style i'm tough i'm like
listen you know i want everyone to be a
little bit braver and a little bit
bolder and i want you to go be
your best self you know and like
appreciate and love and worship yourself
so i'm all about getting everybody to be
standing in their power a little bit
more but yeah i don't have any time for
[ __ ]
i am pretty much the same way where
jackie and i really differ the most is
we get a lot of
messages and one today in particular
about snooping through like your
boyfriend's
phone are you a snooper not to snoop
kind of girl
oh yeah i think snooping is okay i
completely agree
yeah i mean listen it's like you i have
a right to go through your phone if i'm
dating you and you have a right to go
through mine and that's what we're
leaving
that's where i juggle and i'm allowed to
go through your phone but if you even
come within five feet of my phone i'm
chopping your [ __ ] hand off
see that's how i don't care if anyone
goes through my phone there's nothing
that i have that's secretive you know
what i mean
really that's so funny okay well you
also you have a million projects going
on
new hbo max comedy special your first
and six years it's called evolution it's
much different than a lot of the stuff
you've done it's
very like introspective um
why has it been so long since you
released a comedy special i just didn't
really have that much to say
you know what i mean i got sick of my
own voice and sycamo and sick of stand
up when
there wasn't um something really like
you know
more meaning behind it so this one was
felt more like oh i could make a special
that says something instead of just
you know making a bunch of jokes that
lead nowhere it was more of like a story
and a narrative
so i loved it i went back and then i
found you know fell in love with doing
stand-up again so that's fun
i wasn't expecting to do that yeah and
the vibe is like palpably different
and i feel like we're we really
connected we talk a lot about on the
show about grief because our dad passed
away when we were in high school
and you really go into that on the
special and
i'm curious if you have a piece of
advice for people listening who are
either dealing with grief
or just mourning the loss of someone or
something
well i think it's a good way to look
it's just to you know tr i look at it
like no one's ever gone you know energy
doesn't die it transforms and that's
just science
so clearly you know there's different
probably
someone said this to me the other day
about life and death he said when you're
born
you know before you're born you're in
the womb you know you're
in a sack of fluid and you have no
exposure to anything or anyone
and basically that's one dimension and
when you're born you come into the world
and that's another dimension and so if
you think of dying
as as being born you're just kind of
slipping into another dimension it
doesn't mean you're
you're not here where i can see you but
but you're here still
and i know that to be true because i'm
so much closer to my mom now that she's
dead than i was when she was alive
i talked to my mom all the time and i
know when she's around and i know when
she's not
yeah i think that's i actually
completely agree and i feel like it's
very comforting
for for me and for people who are
grieving just at the thought of like
it's not like poof gone because that's
like the hardest part of losing stuff
but it's like waking up one day and the
person who used to be there
is just like not there anymore yeah no
it is it is
it's very hard to obviously get through
this you know and i
and i'm sorry for your loss but it's
nice to see that you have each other to
lean on you know because that's really
what
that's really what it's all about it's
about being able to share the experience
together and be able to like
go through your grief you know don't try
and cover it up or
stuff it down or push it away it's like
if you can
sit and go with your like go with your
grief and sit in your grief
you get through the anguish and the pain
much quicker
than if you try and just you know
deflect or not talk about it or anything
like that
yeah and if you try and like you know do
it yourself like i feel like for so long
i was like i don't want to talk about it
with anyone like i'll deal with it
myself but like when you have good
people around you
it's so beneficial to like lean on them
because no human being is meant to go
through that alone it's so difficult
yes absolutely no you need that's what
your friends are for and it's you know
it's a powerful thing to ask for help
and it doesn't feel that way a lot of
people have a hard time with that i
definitely did for a long time until i
realized like
you know vulnerability doesn't have to
be weakness it is a strength it's a
strength to be vulnerable
to have enough confidence in yourself to
tell the truth whether it makes you look
sad
angry you know selfish or self-absorbed
or whatever
it's important to it's really important
to be um
truth like you know honest with yourself
about what you're going through
and to go through it not to try and
hopscotch around it
comes out in other ways regardless it's
coming out it's coming out of somewhere
yeah because otherwise it taps you on
the shoulder like 20 years later and
you're like
oh [ __ ] what what is this no 100 and
i feel like it actually gets harder the
more time that like
that the more space that's put between
you and like the moment of loss like
i feel like i'm in a worse place now
than i was like when in high school like
the first day of freshman year when my
dad like dropped out of a heart attack
like i feel like i'm actually dealing
with it worse now
because i didn't deal with it very well
as a child right well you didn't have
the articulation like you didn't have
the words to describe that kind of pain
so now as an adult you're like oh now
you wanna it's like delayed grief right
yes that's what it is yeah yes i know
um one more thing i wanted to ask you
about before we get your advice because
i'm really curious to hear your takes on
some of these things
um you've been talking a lot on your
podcast but also in your special about
like your wellness journey with cannabis
um and i'm curious how you got into that
and like what are some of the benefits
is that something we should be doing
yeah totally microdosing cannabis is a
great way to get through the day
and it really helps like accent certain
situations you know what i mean for me
i have a patient's problem like i find
people incredibly annoying when they're
slow or when they're like things take
too long you know like
transactions take too long so for me it
stands down the edges then that way
where i can just be like oh who gives a
[ __ ] you know i'm not going to get upset
about that and
it mellows me out and i also love it for
sleep
but for other people you know and like
even for writing for punching stuff
up you know there are certain edibles
that kind of give you an
upper and so i love that feeling i love
to get creative on them
um but you have to just direct your own
experience you know
and with micro dosing now everything is
labeled you know exactly what you're
putting in
and what you're getting it's not like
you're getting a cookie you know at a
party
filled with pot and you don't know
what's in it it's so easy to kind of
so it's not that the point isn't to for
me to feel like
oh completely out of control or blotted
it's just supposed to enhance
different experiences so you kind of use
it like
i don't want cannabis to use me i want
to use cannabis
right yeah yeah very interesting
that'll look into it yeah especially
those transactions
that's those transactions that's where
my patience runs that's where my edges
need to be sanded down
for self-checkout machines
yeah exactly if i knew how to use a
self-checkout machine i would love that
oh my god it's torture it really is okay
so we do a weekly by segment called dear
toasters people write in about all their
different problems at work and their
relationship we've selected a few
that we would love to get your advice on
and we'll read them to you and you let
us know what you think
okay first up dear toasters so here's
the situation i'm about to be 25 years
old and i've never had sex
don't get me wrong i've done stuff but
never sex it's not that i haven't had
the opportunity to
i just haven't met the person i want to
experience that with yet
i'm not waiting for marriage and at this
point i'm not really even waiting to be
in love but i just wanted to be with
someone that i like and trust
and am in a committed relationship with
i've never been in a relationship either
i'm very picky and have only dated three
guys
i could see that happening with my
question is now that i'm approaching 25
i feel like this is a huge turn off for
guys
i'm worried that i'll meet a guy i like
and feel like want to grow our
relationship but once he finds out i'm a
25 year old virgin he will want to
balance
how do you think i should approach this
issue when dating in the future without
scaring them away
i've had friends tell me i don't even
have to tell the guy that i don't think
that's smart especially if i want to be
in a healthy relationship with them
i've also had people tell me they won't
care but i just don't buy that
any advice or insight would be much
appreciated since you all have great
insight
thank you ace rdh virgin
what do you think well that's a that's
old to not have had sex
but if she really wants to wait then
that's her decision you know i mean yeah
if you
and stop projecting all of the things
that are gonna go wrong about
if you don't do it and if you tell your
next boyfriend that he's not gonna want
you i mean that is
you're creating a total negative
dialogue in your head that doesn't even
exist yet
so like we all do this we all have these
voices in our head that sets up
all the things that could go wrong
instead of thinking about all the things
that could go right
my advice if she if she was looking to
have sex i'd be like just find somebody
to have sex
with soon so you can get the ball
rolling and then
you know if you can't if you really want
to be with somebody that you trust and
you're in a relationship with
then yeah you got to make the effort to
make that happen and don't worry about
your being a virgin some guy's gonna
love that
yeah i i think that the road of not
telling someone is deeply problematic
and i really don't suggest that at
all yeah i think but i also think like
it's clearly a big
something that's important to her and i
think that the right person for her will
appreciate this about her and i think it
could be in like a nice
place maybe she'll need a fellow virgin
yeah that's great yeah that's true
there's probably virgin sites out there
where virgins can hook up with other
virgins right totally i feel like virgin
hood has been like really like
a bad stigma ever since colton underwood
like one on the bachelor like everyone
made fun of him for being
like a 29 year old virgin but it's a
choice and it's lovely
yeah yeah it's it's definitely a choice
i just i wouldn't vote i agree with you
chelsea i wouldn't focus on the negative
things that could happen like
wait for those things to happen and then
we can we can worry about right like
these potential scenarios are just
living rent free in your mind when
they literally are not even ever gonna
happen yeah right exactly set yourself
up for success
yes okay next one dear toasters i need
advice my long-term boyfriend and i had
a coveted breakup
there was no bad blood no cheating or
anything like that i just felt we were
in different places in life and i needed
my space
we left things as we both need space and
time to work on ourselves and we'll see
what happens in the future if it's meant
to be
fast forward four months post breakup
and he reaches out to me saying he still
loves me and wants to try and work it
out
but the thing is i had a rough night one
night a few weeks ago and decided to log
into his instagram because i know his
password
i know this is wrong and horrible but i
couldn't help myself his dms were
filled with him messaging other girls so
much flirting and talking about planning
dates it made me stick to my stomach
now i don't know what to do i can never
admit i read his dms but it's caused me
so much confusion
do i want him back now because i'm
jealous if he's getting attention from
other girls
does he actually want to get back
together with me if so why is he
planning on their dates
also part of me is like bucky for
sliding into other girls dms while i'm
just over here working on myself
any advice love a very confused toaster
yeah that's a tough one well aren't they
weren't they broken up she said were
they broken yes
yes and they were supposed to be working
on themselves and he's working on the
dms and she feels like
he can't really want to get back
together with her if he's been like
spending all this time
right also if i were her i would feel
like you know he he
shot his shot and it didn't seem like
i'm the only one left we're responding
and so he's
he's back to her i don't know this would
run me the wrong way
oh yeah well i think it's already rubbed
like the whole thing has already cut him
loose like it's already
there's bad vibes going around if you're
scrolling through his phone like that
like i'm all for it
you know like i am all for going through
someone's phone but not in this
circumstance because they're not
together they're not in a relationship
they're you know what i mean so like you
already overstepped
and that was invasive so there's just
too much ickiness around this so it's
better to cut the cord and move on i
think
and there's a reason it didn't work out
like this is obviously not your person
so i wouldn't invest any more time or
energy
into like scrolling through his dms or
even giving this any more an effort
because you've already decided this is
not the man for you yeah if you broke up
for a reason i would stick with that
kind of instinct
yeah and i think the dm's you can use
those to just further solidify why you
need to move on
okay third and final dear toasters i
need to know if i'm being a [ __ ]
my boyfriend of three and a half years
and i have a very honest and trusting
relationship we're transparent with each
other about who we hang out with
we both have close friends of the
opposite sex etc but this is something i
was not prepared for
my ex-boyfriend recently got hired at my
current boyfriend's job and they work
very closely together
they're becoming work friends and are
spending most of their work day together
this aggravates the [ __ ] out of me this
guy is my ex for a reason he made my
life
miserable i don't understand why my
boyfriend is okay with palling around
with someone who was once so horrible to
me
i talked to him about it and he brushed
it off because they're just work friends
my question is am i overreacting we've
never been the type of couple that says
you can't be friends with this person
i don't know how to feel thank you a
bitter aggravated toaster
but we don't know what level of abusive
he was
right like what emotionally abusive
physically abusive what are we talking
about
well i mean either one isn't really
acceptable but yeah that's so annoying i
hate when people are not loyal like i
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
you know your boyfriend isn't even
protective over you like that drives me
up a wall if you have a boyfriend that's
not like no i'm never going to hang out
with that guy
yeah her boyfriend sounds like a little
bit of a dud i think she should be
[ __ ] pissed
yeah it's like it's seemingly not a big
deal but there's actually a lot of
undercover red flags about this like
first of all just respect the fact that
i don't want you hanging out with this
person don't like fight me back so you
can have like a bromance with your work
friend
and second of all like he should have
liked this guy like if this guy
was however he was she like and he knows
about it he should like punch him in the
office and get suspended and go to hr
yeah i agree i don't think you're being
a [ __ ] i think this is cause for
concern
yeah i mean you might be sl yeah i mean
if if if it wasn't like a real like if
if the relationship was okay and they
broke up and she just didn't like how it
ended and they're hanging out then she
kind of is overreacting but if he truly
is an
[ __ ] you know like and and did things
that
are are kind of unforgivable then yeah
your boyfriend shouldn't be hanging out
with him
yeah and your boyfriend needs to get a
spine what is he lindsey graham
no this is some spineless like first
season housewife lifetime
there's other people in the workplace to
pal around with 100 do you work at a
startup like how many people work there
there's always other co-workers
always um well that is our show everyone
chelsea's podcast with ir radio is
called dear chelsea it's available
anywhere you get your podcast
her new special evolution is streaming
on hbo max thank you so much for being
here
you're an icon we love you and you're
the best oh
love you girls thanks have a great day